The Blind Man Who Invented Cruise Control
While speed governing systems have been around
on automobiles almost as long as they have
existed (the first known one was installed
on a Wilson-Pilcher car in 1900) and similar
systems have been around long before that
to control steam engines (as far back as the
17th century), the invention of the modern
cruise control system is credited to inventor
and Automotive Hall of Famer, Ralph Teetor-
a man who couldn’t actually drive due to
being completely blind.
The inspiration for the cruise control system
struck Teetor while he was riding with his
lawyer in the 1940s.
He noticed the lawyer had a tendency to slow
down while talking and speed up while listening.
This annoyed Teetor, who decided to come up
with a device to control the speed of the
car automatically.
After several years of tinkering, in 1948
he filed his first patent for a device to
accomplish just this.
(US 2519859)
It took him almost another decade, and a few
more patents filed improving his original
device, to finally come up with a version
that would be installed on a commercially
sold vehicle.
The first cars to boast the new technology
were the 1958 models of the Chrysler Imperial,
New Yorker and Windsor.
By 1960, cruise control was a standard feature
on all Cadillacs.
The system worked by calculating ground speed
based on driveshaft rotations.
It then used a solenoid, as needed, to vary
the position of the throttle cable.
Cruise control went by several names in the
early days.
It was initially called everything from “Speedostat,”
to “Touchomatic” and “Auto-Pilot.”
It was Chrysler who finally came up with the
“cruise control” name.
(Personally, I’d have preferred “Speedostat”…)
Different versions of the cruise control system
were soon invented by various people, with
the systems receiving a big boost in popularity
thanks to the oil crisis of the 1970s and
the savings in fuel a cruise control system
can potentially have, depending on one’s
driving habits.
Today, the cruise control systems are still
evolving, including beginning to incorporate
some more advanced self-driving features such
as automatic braking.
As for Teetor, he was blinded in an accident
when he was five-years-old, though he never
let it slow him down.
In fact, in the December 21, 1902 edition
of the New York Herald, Teetor, who at the
time was 12 years old, made it into a featured
article:
A constructor of miniature dynamos and other
machinery at 10 and thoroughly versed in all
that pertains to their operation, and at 12
the builder of an automobile that carries
him about the streets of his native town and
far out upon the country roads at a speed
of from 18 to 25 miles an hour, is the remarkable
record of Ralph Teetor of Hagerstown, Indiana.
The specific automobile referenced here was
a one-cylinder car that, with the help of
a cousin, he built using an old engine someone
threw away.
He then machined the necessary parts to re-build
the engine and soon had himself a working
vehicle, all at the age of 12.
This blind mechanical prodigy went on to graduate
near the top of his class in 1912 with a degree
in mechanical engineering from the University
of Pennsylvania.
A few years later, he developed a technology
for dynamically balancing steam turbine rotors
which was used in torpedo boat destroyers
during World War I.
For his day job, Teetor became a mechanical
engineer for his family’s company, Light
Inspection Car Company of Hagerstown, Indiana
in the 1930s.
The company was later renamed the Perfect
Circle Corporation.
Perfect Circle provided piston rings to companies
like General Motors, Studebaker, Packard and
Chrysler.
Teetor soon advanced to Vice President of
Engineering for the company and was eventually
named President.
In the interim, he also developed an early
gas powered lawn mower and a new kind of fishing
rod handle that “provide[d] a fishing pole
handle which comfortably fits the fisherman’s
hand in a natural and effortless position
and permits a convenient and easy manipulation
of the reel by the thumb of the hand while
it is firmly gripping the handle,” (US 1898323)
along with filing many other patents throughout
his life.
He was also elected the president of the Society
of Automotive Engineers (SAE) in 1936.
In 1963, SAE went ahead and named an award
after him, the Ralph R. Teetor Educational
Award which “honors those young educators
who are successfully preparing engineers for
meeting the challenges that face society.”
In 1965, he also received two honorary degrees,
one from the Indiana Institute of Technology
(Doctor of Engineering), and one from Earlham
College (Doctor of Law), among many other
awards and honors.
He died at the ripe old age of 91 on February
15, 1982.